AINSLEY: THE UNITED STATES
SLOWLY PHASING BACK TO NORMALCY
THIS MORNING AS AMERICANS
COMMEMORATE A MEMORIAL DAY
UNLIKE ANY OTHER.
TODAY THREE STATES ARE EASING
THOSE STRICT COVID-19
RESTRICTIONS, PETE.
PETE: YUP, HAIR SALONS, BARBER
SHOPS AND MASSAGE THERAPY
BUSINESSES MAY OPEN THEIR DOORS
IN KENTUCKY AS WELL ASTHMAS MASS
, THE STATE ALSO ALLOWING
LABS TO REOPEN AND OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES LIKE HUNTING, BOATING
, AND FISHING MAY RESUME.
STEVE: MEANWHILE, IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK CAMPGROUNDS AND RV
PARKS ARE BACK IN
BUSINESS, ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY,
MORE THAN 366,000 PEOPLE HAVE
RECOVERED FROM THE VIRUS SO FAR
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THAT IS VERY PROMISING.
LET’S BRING IN RIGHT NOW,
JOINING US LIVE FROM WASHINGTON
D.C. THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, MIKE PENCE,
WHO IS LIVE AT THE PENTAGON.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, ALL.
STEVE: IT’S GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU’VE BEEN
HEADING UP THE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE FOR A COUPLE MONTHS NOW.
WHEN YOU SEE SO MANY OF THE
STATES START TO REOPEN, BUT
THEN YOU SEE THOSE IMAGES OF
AMERICA WHICH IS CLEARLY
PANDEMIC-FATIGUED AND YOU SEE
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE ON THE
BEACH OR  BOARDWALK AND THEY
ARE SHOULDER-TO-SHOULDER AND I’M
SURE DR.  BIRX WOULD SAY THEY’RE
TOO CLOSE IF NOT WEARING A MASK,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THOSE IMAGES
GIVEN THAT THE WHOLE IDEA IS TO
KEEP SIX FEET FROM EACH OTHER
AND IF YOU DON’T THERE COULD BE
TROUBLE.
>> WELL FIRST, STEVE, LET ME
SAY ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY, OUR
HEARTS AND OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH
THE FAMILIES OF ALL OF OUR
FALLEN.
I’M NOT FAR FROM ARLINGTON
NATIONAL CEMETERY, I’LL BE WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THE FIRST LADY
IN JUST A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME,
AND THIS MEMORIAL DAY IN THE
MIDST OF THIS CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC IS
PARTICULARLY GRIEVOUS, BECAUSE
COMMUNITIES LARGE AND SMALL
GENERALLY COME TOGETHER, THEY
GET THEIR ARMS AROUND THOSE GOLD
STAR FAMILIES BUT TODAY THERE
WILL BE MORE SEPARATION AND MORE
DISTANCE AND I JUST WANT THEM
ALL TO KNOW THEY’RE EN OUR
HEARTS TODAY, BUT YOU KNOW, YOU
JUST RECITED A LOT OF PROGRESS
ON REOPENING AMERICA, AND I MUST
TELL YOU, THE PRESIDENT AND I
ARE VERY CONFIDENT THAT AS NOW
, ALL 50 STATES HAVE BEGUN
THE PROCESS OF REOPENING OUR
COUNTRY, THAT WHILE THERE MAY BE
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE WOULD DO
WELL TO BE REMINDED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING REGULAR HYGIENE, WE
HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT AS
THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE MORE L
UCENT IN THE DAYS AHEAD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
STEP FORWARD AND PUT THIS
COUNTRY BACK TO WORK IN A
SAFE AND IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY.
AINSLEY: MR. VICE PRESIDENT THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT
SCHOOLS HE SAID SCHOOLS IN OUR
COUNTRY SHOULD BE OPENED ASAP,
MUCH VERY GOOD INFORMATION NOW
AVAILABLE.
WHAT’S THE LATEST ON THIS
BECAUSE WE’RE MANY PEOPLE
IN NEW YORK CITY, FOR INSTANCE
ARE WONDERING ARE THEIR KIDS
GOING TO BE GOING BACK-TO-SCHOOL
IF NOT SHOULD WE ENROLL THEM
SOMEWHERE ELSE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT’S
IMPORTANT TO REFLECT TODAY ON
TWO THINGS.
I THINK, AINSLEY, NUMBER ONE IS
THE MORE THAN 98,000 AMERICANS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES OUR
HEARTS ARE WITH THEIR FAMILIES
ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY AS WELL,
BUT I THINK WE ALSO DO WELL TO
REFLECT ON THE FACT THAT BECAUSE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EMBRACE THE
PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP,
LISTEN TO STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES, THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
SPARED THE HEARTACHE OF THAT
LOSS, AND WE’VE SEEN REAL
PROGRESS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE
DECLINING, WE’VE SEEN A STEADY
DECLINE IN CASES, NEW CASES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, FATALITIES CONTINUE
TO DECLINE.
YOU SAW THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
AS YOU MENTIONED THEIR STATE SAY
THAT NEW YORK IS ESSENTIALLY
BACK WHERE THEY STARTED.
BACK IN MARCH, AND SO WE ARE ON
THE FAR SIDE OF THIS EPIDEMIC IN
MANY OF THE PLACES MOST IMPACTED
AND THAT’S GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY, NOT JUST TO
ISSUE AS WE DID NOW MORE THAN A
MONTH AGO, THE GUIDELINES TO
OPEN UP AMERICA AGAIN BUT THE
CDC AND THE TASK FORCE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PRODUCE
USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT HOW WE
CAN BRING BACK OUR SCHOOLS, HOW
WE CAN BRING BACK SUMMER CAMPS,
HOW WE CAN GO BACK TO CHURCHES
AND SYNAGOGUES AND MOSQUES AND
ENJOY IN A SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE
WAY OUR FREEDOMS OF RELIGION, SO
WE’RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS WE’LL BE WELCOMING
THEM TO THE WHITE HOUSE SOON,
AND WE HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE
THAT WHETHER IT BE OUR
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
OR  WHETHER IT BE PRIMARY AND
SECONDARY EDUCATION THAT WE’RE
IN MOST AREAS OF THE COUNTRY,
WE’RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
KIDS BACK-TO-SCHOOL IN A
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE WAY.
PETE: MR. VICE PRESIDENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
YOU KNOW THERE IS AN  ONGOING
TENSION BETWEEN BLUE STATE
GOVERNORS, GOVERNORS KEEPING
STATES LOCKED DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND THE UNCERTAINTY THAT
CREATES.
I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT JUST PUT OUT A
TWEET MOMENTS AGO THAT PERTAINS
TO THIS AND WE WANT YOUR
REACTION.
HE SAID I LOVE THE GREAT STATE
OF NORTH CAROLINA, SO MUCH SO
THAT I INSISTED ON HAVING THE  R
NC, REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
CONVENTION IN CHARLOTTE AT THE
END OF AUGUST.
UNFORTUNATELY, DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR
ROY COOPER IS STILL IN SHUTDOWN
MOOD AND UNABLE TO
GUARANTEE THAT BY AUGUST WE WILL
BE ALLOWED FULL ATTENDANCE IN
THE ARENA.
IN OTHER WORDS WE’LL BE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUILDING THE
ARENA TO A VERY HIGH
STANDARD WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR WOULD A
ROW THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
FULLY OCCUPY THE SPACE.
PLANS ARE BEING MADE BY MANY
THOUSANDS REPUBLICANS AND OTHERS
TO HEAD TO NORTH CAROLINA IN
AUGUST THEY MUST BE IMMEDIATELY
GIVEN AN ANSWER BY THE GOVERNOR
AS TO WHETHER OR  NOT THE SPACE
WILL BE ALLOWED TO BE FULLY
OCCUPIED, IF NOT WE WILL BE
RELUCTANTLY FORCED TO FIND WITH
ALL THE JOBS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IT BRINGS ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION
SITE, THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I
WANT TO DO.
THANK YOU, AND I LOVE THE PEOPLE
OF NORTH CAROLINA.
SO, THIS IS A MACRO LOOK AT
SOMETHING THAT’S HAPPENED AT THE
SMALLER LEVEL AS WELL.
GOVERNORS LOGGING DOWN,
DECISIONS CAN’T BE MADE,
BUSINESSES BEING HIT.
FIRST IF YOU WOULD, TO THE RNC
AND THE CONVENTION AND
POSSIBILITY OF CHANGING IT AND
THEN THE QUESTION OVERALL.
>> WELL, IT’S AN ISSUE WE’VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT, PETE,
BECAUSE THESE NATIONAL
CONVECTION CONVENTIONS LITERALLY
TAKE MANY MONTHS TO ORGANIZE AND
PREPARE, AND YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY, WE
THINK OF TEXAS, WE THINK OF
FLORIDA, GEORGIA, THE LAST TWO
STATES I VISITED LAST WEEK THAT
HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS ON
REOPENING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
REOPENING THEIR ECONOMIES,
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
ABSOLUTELY INTENT ON INSURING
THAT AS WE SEE OUR NATION
CONTINUE TO MAKE STEADY PROGRESS
ON PUTTING THE CORONAVIRUS
EPIDEMIC IN THE PAST THAT COME
THIS AUGUST, WE’LL BE ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER IN A SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE VENUE, AND RE
NOMINATE PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP FOR FOUR MORE YEARS, BUT
WHAT YOU’RE HEARING THE
PRESIDENT SAY TODAY IS JUST
A VERY REASONABLE REQUEST IF THE
GOVERNOR OF NORTH CAROLINA, WE
ALL WANT TO BE IN CHARLOTTE, WE
LOVE NORTH CAROLINA, BUT HAVING
A SENSE NOW IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL BECAUSE OF THE IMMENSE
PREPARATIONS THAT ARE INVOLVED
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR COOPER,
GETTING A SWIFT RESPONSE AND IF
NEEDS BE, IF NEEDS BE, MOVING
THE NATIONAL CONVENTION TO A
STATE THAT IS FARTHER ALONG ON
REOPENING AND CAN SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE WE CAN GATHER THERE.
STEVE: MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
EARLIER IN TODAY’S PROGRAM, WE
TALKED TO A COUPLE OF GUYS WHO
OWN A DINER IN PENNSYLVANIA.
YORK, PENNSYLVANIA AND THEY
REOPENED ON MOTHERS DAY WEEKEND,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNOR KEPT THE STATE
CLOSED DOWN.
THEY DEFIED THE ORDER.
THEY APPEARED ON OUR PROGRAM I
THINK ABOUT FOUR DAYS AGO, AND
WITHIN JUST A FEW HOURS, THEN
THE STATE SUSPENDED THEIR
LICENSE AND SAID YOU GOT TO
CLOSE.
THEY ARE STILL OPEN THIS MORNING
WE TALKED TO THEM LISTEN TO WHAT
THEY HAD TO SAY EARLIER.
>> GOVERNOR WOLF THREW A LITTLE
TEMPER TANTRUM AND DECIDED TO
SUSPEND THROUGH EMERGENCY POWERS
TO SUSPEND OUR LICENSES.
>> BUT IT’S NOT ABOUT THE DINER
IT’S ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WANT THEIR FREEDOM.
EVERY CUSTOMER COMES IN, THEY
THANK US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING OPEN.
>> WE PROVIDE SOMETHING THAT
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS RIGHT NOW,
TO FLATTEN THIS FEAR AND
PROGRESS FORWARD.
STEVE: FLATTEN THE FEAR.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, CAN YOU
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION WITH
CERTAIN BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CERTAIN LOCATIONS THAT HAVE
NOT REOPENED YET?
>> WELL, I REALLY CAN, STEVE
AND IT’S THE REASON WHY EVEN
BEFORE THE 45 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
US ISSUE GUIDELINES TO OPEN UP
AMERICA AGAIN, AND WE MADE IT
CLEAR TO GOVERNOR WOLF AND
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT THEY COULD IMPLEMENT THAT
GUIDANCE NOT JUST ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS BUT ON A COUNTY-BY-COUNTY
BASIS, AND THIS LAST WEEK, I
ACTUALLY WAS ABLE TO GRAB LUNCH
IN A NICE DINER IN GEORGIA,
ANOTHER ONE IN FLORIDA.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THAT WE CAN SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY REOPEN OUR
RESTAURANTS IN MANY PLACES
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND WE’RE
JUST GOING TO CONTINUE TO URGE
GOVERNOR WOLF AND OTHER GOVERNOR
S AROUND THE COUNTRY TO
LOOK FOR THOSE OPPORTUNITIES,
NOT TO USE THE COERCE EVER POWER
OF THE STATE BUT TO FIND WAYS TO
LITERALLY RESTORE THE FREEDOMS
THAT WE ALL CHERISH.
THIS IS A FREEDOM-LOVING COUNTRY
TODAY, WE FEEL ON OUR HEARTS A
PARTICULAR WEIGHT OF GRATITUDE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AND
DIED FOR THAT FREEDOM AND WE’RE
JUST GOING TO CONTINUE IN ALL OF
OUR INTERACTIONS WITH GOVERNORS
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO ENCOURAGE
THEM, TO RESTORE THEIR ECONOMY,
REOPEN THEIR COUNTRY, AND WE’RE
WORKING IN FULL PARTNERSHIP WITH
GOVERNORS TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE TESTING SUPPLIES AND
RESOURCES AND PPE NECESSARY
TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT IN
A WAY THAT PUTS THE HEALTH OF
THEIR CITIZENS, EVEN RIGHT
ALONGSIDE THE HEALTH OF A
GROWING ECONOMY.
AINSLEY: UH-HUH, MR. VICE
PRESIDENT WE HEARD THE AIRPLANE
FLYING THAT REMINDS ME OF THE
AIR FORCE AND ALL OF THE
BRANCHES THAT I KNOW YOUR
SON IS SERVING, PETE YOU SERVED,
MY DAD SERVED, MY GRANDFATHERS,
STEVE MANY IN YOUR FAMILY SERVED
WHAT THE IS YOUR MESSAGE ON THIS
MEMORIAL DAY, BY THE WAY I
READ YOUR OP-ED CALLED THIS
MEMORIAL DAY OUR FREEDOMS
ARE CHERISHED EVEN MORE AND HERE
IS WHY.
IT WAS BEAUTIFULLY WRITTEN BUT
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE FOR OUR
GREAT COUNTRY?
>> THANK YOU.
WELL, THIS MESSAGE ON THIS
MEMORIAL DAY EVEN IN THE
MIDST OF THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES, IS THAT THIS FREEDOM-LOV
ING NATION KNOWS
THAT FREEDOM ISN’T FREE, AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL EVERY DAY FOR  ALL
OF THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE
IN THE ARMY, NAVY, AIR FORCE,
MARINES AND COAST GUARD BUT
TODAY’S THE DAY THAT WE REMEMBER
THOSE WHO SERVED AND FELL IN
BATTLE, AND WHEN THE PRESIDENT
AND I AND THE FIRST LADY AND
KAREN GATHER IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AT ARLINGTON WILL LAY A
WREATH, WILL SAY A PRAYER AND I
JUST ENCOURAGE PEOPLE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY TO REMEMBER THE
FAMILIES OF OUR FALLEN IN
YOUR PRAYERS ESPECIALLY THIS DAY
WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE OUT WAVING
FLAGS AND STANDING UP FOR
FREEDOM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES,
THIS MEMORIAL DAY, I THINK WE DO
FEEL A SPECIAL WEIGHT OF
GRATITUDE TO THOSE WHO DEFENDED
THAT FREEDOM THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY, WHO PAID THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE FOR OUR FREEDOM, AND
THEY ARE IN OUR HEARTS TODAY,
THEY ARE IN OUR PRAYERS AND EACH
OF THEM I WANT THEM TO KNOW THIS
MEMORIAL DAY WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THEM, AND THEIR
LOVED ONES WHO DEMONSTRATED THAT
WHAT THE BIBLE SAYS IS NO
GREATER LOVE, NO GREATER LOVE IS
A MAN THAN HE SHOULD LAY DOWN
HIS LIFE FOR HIS FRIENDS AND
TODAY WE REMEMBER ALL THE MEN
AND WOMEN THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY
WHO HAVE LAID DOWN THEIR LIVES
FOR OUR FREEDOM.
STEVE: INDEED.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE WILL SEE YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT AT THE TOMB OF THE
UNKNOWNS VERY SHORTLY AT